Katrina:  然后我们有那种大音箱不
Katrina: Do we have one of those big speakers?
Shure:  这个可以有
Shure: We can get one.
Katrina:  如果在外面玩的话放点音乐啥
Katrina: If we're playing outside, we can play some music or something.
Jake: 嗯就放刚刚那个曲子
Jake: Yeah, play that tune we just heard.
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina:  嗯大东北
Katrina: Hmm, from the North
Lucia: 对
Katrina:  知识问答自我介绍
Jake: 打死我吧
Jake: 这个花瓶
Katrina:  这是真的酒还是假酒
Jake: 假酒
Katrina: 啊我还以为你们已经喝了
Jake: 这是我的水瓶
Jake: 没有啥毛病哦
Jake: There's nothing wrong with it.
Katrina:  再拿起出来干一口
Katrina: Take another sip.
Jake: 那花瓶拿走了还倒
Jake: The vase was taken away but still spilled.
Katrina:  这多的话等会就放
Katrina: If there's more, we can put it later.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Katrina:  这花瓶好
Katrina: This vase is nice.
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Careful.
Shure: 完了
Shure: It's over.
Alice: 叮零咣当的
Alice: Clattering noise.
Shure:  这是个保温杯
Shure: It's a thermos.
Lucia: 啊这居然是保温杯
Lucia: Oh, it's actually a thermos.
Shure:  一听就是304不锈钢
Shure: You can tell it's 304 stainless steel.
Jake: 呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Lucia: 厉害了
Lucia: Impressive.
Jake: 很懂啊大东北
Jake: You really know your stuff, big Northeast.
Jake: 衬衫的是吧
Jake: It's a shirt, right?
Jake: 东北钢铁厂
Jake: Northeastern Steel Plant.
Shure:  鞍钢
Shure:  这字写的太好看了
Shure: The handwriting is beautiful.
Shure:  真的
Shure: Really.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  可歌可泣
Shure: So moving.
Jake: 一看就是中文
Jake: You can tell it's Chinese.
Shure:  哦我们还要写个英文版吗
Shure: Oh, do we need to write an English version?
Jake:: 不用不用不用
Jake: 哎呦对
Jake: Oh yeah, right.
Jake: 我们字写的好
Jake: We write well.
Shure: : 我们应该international一点
Shure:  你看我那个英文就明显跟这个
Shure: You see, my English is clearly better than this.
Jake: 那好下面开始写英文吧
Jake: Alright, let's start writing in English then.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Jake:时间线
Jake: Timeline.
Jake: 来
Jake: Let's go.
Shure: 来咱俩换一下
Shure: Let's switch places.
Shure:  你去那边坐一会去
Shure: You go sit over there for a bit.
Jake: 或坐这
Jake: Or sit here.
Shure:  timeline
Shure: Timeline.
Jake:为啥是俩词
Jake: Why is it two words?
Alice: 时间线吧
Alice: Just call it a timeline.
Jake: 为啥是俩词
Jake: Why is it two words?
Jake: 这个
Jake: This...
Jake:也行也行
Jake: It's fine, it's fine.
Shure:  强调一下这个line
Shure: Emphasize this "line".
Jake:好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Shure: 线
Shure: Line.
Shure:  首先我们几点入场
Shure: First, what time do we enter?
Jake: 3点 3点吧
Jake: 3 o'clock. 3 o'clock, right?
Jake: 应该是2点到3点逐步入场
Jake: It should be between 2 and 3 o'clock gradually.
Jake: 然后前面可能签到的人
Jake: Then the people who signed in earlier.
Katrina: 逛逛
Katrina: Can stroll around.
Jake: 对给他们一点活动
Jake: Yeah, give them some activities.
Shure:  鹌鹑
Shure: Quail.
Jake:哈哈神经
Jake: Haha, you're crazy.
Shure:  入场是怎么拍的吗
Shure: How do we film the entry?
Lucia: 2点半到3点
Lucia: From 2:30 to 3.
Shure:  two
Shure: Two.
Shure:  okay对
Shure: Okay, yes.
Jake: 这意思就是3点之前
Jake: That means before 3 o'clock.
Jake: 我们搞一些flexible的游戏或者活动
Jake: We'll have some flexible games or activities.
Jake: 然后3点准时干点什么东西
Jake: Then at 3 o'clock sharp, we do something.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  game
Shure: Game.
Shure:  before
Shure: Before.
Shure:  是不是污染数据集
Shure: Does it contaminate the data?
Jake: 不污染
Jake: It doesn't.
Jake: 这是人类的正常行为
Jake: It's normal human behavior.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: ok第二点还有什么
Shure: Okay, what's the second point?
Shure:  还有什么
Shure: What else?
Jake: 然后3点干啥了
Jake: Then what do we do at 3 o'clock?
Jake: 3点开始就有知识问答和自我介绍
Jake: Starting at 3, there will be a Q&A and self-introductions.
Shure:  那这这些呢
Shure: What about these?
Katrina:  这些就是我们要让他们先获得货币
Katrina: These are for them to earn currency first.
Katrina:  以后我们再推销我们自己的产品
Katrina: Then we'll promote our own products.
Katrina:  我其实感觉不确定
Katrina: I'm actually not sure.
Katrina:  他们到底是E人还是I人
Katrina: Are they E types or I types?
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: Do you know?
Katrina:  就万一
Katrina: Just in case...
Shure: OK
Shure: Okay.
Katrina:  其实可能不会持续很长的时间
Katrina: It might not last very long.
Katrina:  自我介绍
Katrina: The self-introductions.
Katrina: 知识问答40分钟吧
Katrina: Q&A for 40 minutes, I guess.
Katrina:  加自我介绍
Katrina: Plus self-introductions.
Shure:  您说也行
Shure: That works too.
Jake: 抢答对吧
Jake: Quick answers, right?
Katrina:  嗯很快其实
Katrina: Yeah, it'll be quick actually.
Jake: 对对挺好
Jake: Yeah, sounds good.
Shure:  and知识问答
Shure: And the Q&A.
Katrina: QA
Katrina: QA.
Shure: 嗷
Shure: Oh.
Jake:妙啊
Jake: Brilliant.
Shure:  OK
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  第3点
Shure: The third point.
Katrina:  然后就每个人介绍自己做的这个
Katrina: Then everyone introduces what they are doing.
Katrina:  然后就跟他们说
Katrina: And then we tell them...
Katrina:  他们可以拿他们的货币来
Katrina: They can use their currency to...
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake:大家插会电吧
Jake: Let's plug in the power.
Jake: 你们继续聊
Jake: You all keep talking.
Jake: 我给大家发线
Jake: I'll hand out the cables.
Katrina:  45个
Katrina: Forty-five of them.
Shure:  可以  然后呢
Shure: Alright, then?
Jake: 哦你一直插着的
Jake: Oh, you've been plugged in.
Shure:  我一直插着充电宝
Shure: I've been plugged into the power bank.
Jake: 给我
Jake: Give it to me.
Jake: 这个是谁的
Jake: Whose is this?
Katrina:  我我的
Katrina: It's mine.
Jake: 好那你插上吧少一个
Jake: Alright, then plug it in, we're missing one.
Lucia: 我也插上了
Lucia: I plugged mine in too.
Shure:  3
Shure: 3
Katrina: 介绍自己的产品吗
Katrina: Are we introducing our products?
Katrina:  每个人
Katrina: Everyone?
Shure:  啊3就开始拍卖
Shure: Ah, at 3 we start the auction.
Shure:  怎么说
Shure: What do you think?
Lucia: auction
Lucia: Auction.
Shure:  auction啊AUC
Shure: Auction, AUC.
Jake: 你也插一个吧
Jake: You should plug one in too.
Shure: auction
Shure: Auction.
Alice: 哦谢谢
Alice: Oh, thanks.
Shure:  预计3:40到
Shure: Estimated arrival at 3:40.
Lucia: 一个小时 或许
Lucia: About an hour, maybe.
Shure:  4点半吧差不多
Shure: Around 4:30, approximately.
Katrina:  你这拍卖
Katrina: This auction...
Katrina:  指的是拍卖他们自己带带的东西
Katrina: Are we auctioning the stuff they brought?
Katrina:  还是谁来拍卖
Katrina: Or who's auctioning?
Shure:  自己的和
Shure: Their own stuff and...
Katrina: 他们自己带的
Katrina: The stuff they brought?
Katrina:  对和我们的
Katrina: Yes, and ours.
Lucia: 和咱们的产品
Lucia: And our products.
Katrina:  那应该不止一个小时吧
Katrina: Then it should take more than an hour.
Lucia: 不止吗那就再长一个半小时
Lucia: More than that? Then maybe an hour and a half.
Katrina:  一个半小时差不多
Katrina: An hour and a half sounds about right.
Katrina:  主要是看他们
Katrina: Depends on them.
Shure: 我们可以细分
Shure: We can split it up.
Shure:  这个是他们自己的部分
Shure: This part is their stuff.
Shure:  这是guest part
Shure: This is the guest part.
Katrina:  这些这些
Katrina: These, these...
Katrina:  这些gets
Katrina: These things.
Katrina:  他们带多少东西
Katrina: How much stuff did they bring?
Lucia: 以及他们是I人还是E人
Lucia: And are they introverts or extroverts?
Katrina:  对这就不确定
Katrina: Right, that's uncertain.
Shure:  呃然后还有什么我们的
Shure: Uh, and what else do we have?
Shure:  或者我们可以提前来
Shure: Or we can come early.
Shure:  活跃一下这个气氛
Shure: To liven up the atmosphere.
Katrina:  嗯对
Katrina: Yeah, right.
Katrina:  我觉得我们先开始吧
Katrina: I think we should start first.
Shure:  我们先开始
Shure: Let's start first.
Katrina:  3:40到4点半
Katrina: From 3:40 to 4:30
Katrina:  是我们先开始
Katrina: We'll start first
Shure:  我们
Shure: We
Katrina: 每个人
Katrina: Everyone
Shure: 会会这么
Shure: Will this
Katrina: 七八分钟差不多
Katrina: About seven or eight minutes
Katrina:  七八分钟
Katrina: Seven or eight minutes
Katrina:  那40分钟差不多
Katrina: So, about 40 minutes
Katrina:  那就4:20
Katrina: That makes it 4:20
Shure: 4:20吧
Shure: 4:20 then
Lucia: 或者
Lucia: Or
Lucia: 直接把他们把这段变成我们整体的
Lucia: Just turn this part into our overall
Lucia: 一个
Lucia: One
Lucia: 怎么形容一个小续集也行
Lucia: How to describe it, like a small sequel
Lucia: 就是可以让他们先
Lucia: We can let them go first
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah
Lucia: 就是如果对咱们整体的这个手工制品
Lucia: If it’s about our overall handmade products
Lucia: 感觉就好比我们是一个商家一样
Lucia: It’s like we are a business
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm
Lucia: 只不过使用的是这个虚拟货币
Lucia: But using this virtual currency
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yeah
Lucia: 然后如果大家玩的比较高兴的
Lucia: And if everyone is having fun
Lucia: 话就后面让他们在自己之间交换
Lucia: Then let them exchange among themselves later
Katrina:  都行也可以
Katrina: That’s fine, it works
Alice:反正现在我们买了花瓶嘛
Alice: Anyway, we bought the vases now
Katrina:  对对对我买6个
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, I bought six
Alice: 还有在哪呢
Alice: Where are they now?
Katrina:  人家都到了
Katrina: They’ve all arrived
Katrina:  但是这花可以让他们自己插
Katrina: But we can let them arrange the flowers themselves
Alice: 就是现在不是醒花吗
Alice: Right now, we’re waking the flowers
Alice: 嗯就是
Alice: Yeah, so
Katrina:  我的意思是
Katrina: What I mean is
Katrina:  可以大家自己搭配自己挑嘛
Katrina: Everyone can pick and match for themselves
Alice: 哦你的意思是
Alice: Oh, you mean
Katrina: 六六个瓶子吗
Katrina: Six vases, right?
Katrina:  然后多的就放这种公共的
Katrina: And the extra ones are for everyone
Katrina:  刚才还有花瓶啥的
Katrina: There were vases earlier too
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yeah
Alice:先醒醒他吧
Alice: Let’s wake them up first
Jake: 我们的食品环节吃饭环下午茶环节
Jake: Our food segment, meal segment, and afternoon tea segment
Jake: 在什么地方
Jake: Where will they be?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Shure:  啊要有一直有一个酒保在那边
Shure: Ah, there should always be a bartender over there
Katrina:  哈哈哈一直有一个酒保
Katrina: Hahaha, always a bartender
Jake: 那酒保在什么位置呢
Jake: So where will the bartender be?
Katrina:  我感觉就外面这里已经很好了
Katrina: I feel like outside here is already good
Jake: 那调酒是在外面
Jake: So the bar is outside
Katrina:  但是但是但是我喝酒
Katrina: But, but, but I drink
Lucia: 调酒是在这个台子上调
Lucia: The bar is on this counter
Jake: 也可以啊在室内然后如果有人
Jake: It could be inside too, and if someone
Shure: 就在这
Shure: Just right here
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow
Lucia: 对刚才那表演就是待在外面的
Lucia: Yeah, the performance earlier was outside
Lucia: 玻璃就可以看到
Lucia: You can see through the glass
Lucia: 调酒师在里面
Lucia: The bartender inside
Lucia: 如何哇好高级啊
Lucia: How amazing, so high-end
Jake:对是是
Jake: Yes, yes
Lucia: 来来一点打光
Lucia: Let's add some lighting
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Lucia: 对我们还有这个影棚灯
Lucia: Yeah, we also have this studio light
Lucia: 虽然这个我们是就一个
Lucia: Even though it's just one
Lucia: 一个灯吗
Lucia: One light, right?
Jake: 没有四个啊
Jake: No, there are four
Lucia: 啊OK
Lucia: Ah, okay
Jake:现在还没装晚一会装一下
Jake: We haven't set them up yet, we'll set them up later
Katrina:  那那下午茶时间要不要弄到4:20之后
Katrina: So should the afternoon tea time be after 4:20?
Katrina:  要不然插在哪个地方
Katrina: Otherwise, when should we fit it in?
Shure: 可以大家边吃边干嘛
Shure: We can eat while doing other things
Lucia: 就我觉得4:20之后就可以
Lucia: I think after 4:20 is fine
Lucia: 因为一般来说
Lucia: Because usually
Lucia: 下午茶就是3点到5点这个时间段
Lucia: Afternoon tea is between 3 and 5 PM
Jake: 就可能我们一一部分人
Jake: So maybe we, a part of us
Jake: 还是我们先做好
Jake: Should we prepare first?
Jake: 我们可以先做好吗
Jake: Can we prepare first?
Alice: 什么
Alice: What?
Jake:就是那些
Jake: Just those
Katrina: 甜品
Katrina: Desserts
Jake:甜品
Jake: Desserts
Tasha:  可以啊
Tasha: Sure, no problem.
Jake:可以先做好
Jake: You can prepare it first.
Katrina:  哎那就是反正他他他的是种子片
Katrina: Oh, so anyway, his is a seed video.
Katrina:  就加甜品
Katrina: Just add desserts.
Katrina:  就在3:40-4:20介绍
Katrina: Introduce it around 3:40-4:20.
Katrina:  然后他作为我们几个的压轴
Katrina: And then he'll be the finale for us.
Katrina:  然后介绍完了以后大家可以分发一下
Katrina: After the introduction, everyone can distribute it.
Katrina:  尝一下他的那个甜品
Katrina: And try his dessert.
Katrina:  对他们是摆台
Katrina: Yeah, they are setting up.
Katrina:  也有钱了嘛
Katrina: And they have money now.
Tasha: 摆台吗
Tasha: Setting up?
Katrina: 摆台吗
Katrina: Setting up?
Jake: 摆什么
Jake: Setting up what?
Tasha: 甜品摆台
Tasha: Dessert setup.
Lucia: 就是 下午茶
Lucia: It's like afternoon tea.
Alice:下午成塔的
Alice: The tower kind.
Tasha: 啊啊
Tasha: Ah, really?
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Seriously?
Alice: 看一下就觉得好看当然可以了
Alice: Just look at it, it's beautiful, of course you can.
Tasha: 嗯好的
Tasha: Hmm, okay.
Tasha: 那就是甜品台做一次要800-1,000呢
Tasha: So, setting up a dessert table costs around 800-1,000.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure:  怎么杨老板突然空手了
Shure: Why is Jake suddenly empty-handed?
Shure:  应该是哈哈哈
Shure: Should be, hahaha.
Jake: 可以可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure, sure.
Tasha: 没有只是买个甜品台架子
Tasha: No, it's just buying a dessert table stand.
Jake: 架子1,000是吧
Jake: The stand is 1,000?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Jake:那是什么
Jake: Then what?
Lucia: 总共的吧
Lucia: Altogether, I think.
Jake: 总共500-1,000
Jake: In total, 500-1,000.
Tasha: 就是你你去做的话
Tasha: If you go and do it.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 去外面吗
Shure: Outside?
Katrina:  哎但是你需不需要很多机器啊
Katrina: But don't you need a lot of machines?
Tasha: 嗯基础的买了
Tasha: Hmm, I bought the basic ones.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Tasha: 厨师机什么的肯定没买
Tasha: The kitchen machine and stuff, definitely not.
Jake: 能能多少钱
Jake: How much can that cost?
Tasha:  嗯不能买
Tasha: Hmm, can't buy it.
Jake: 呵呵呵不能买是什么
Jake: Haha, why can't we buy it?
Jake: 太贵了嗯对啊
Jake: It's too expensive, yeah.
Tasha: 呵呵上万
Tasha: Haha, thousands.
Tasha: 嗯几千块钱吧
Tasha: Yeah, a few thousand bucks.
Jake: OK嗯可以
Jake: OK, sounds good.
Tasha: 甜品台就类似这样子哦
Tasha: The dessert table is like this.
Katrina:  啊看一眼好漂亮啊
Katrina: Ah, look, it's so pretty.
Katrina:  对对对
Katrina: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 差不多是我设想的那个大盘子好漂亮
Lucia: It's almost like the big plate I imagined, so pretty.
Tasha: 到时候坐在这里
Tasha: We'll sit here when the time comes.
Lucia: 可以每次开学术会议的时候就是这样
Lucia: We can do this every time we have an academic meeting.
Tasha: 就是哈哈哈
Katrina:  学术蝗虫
Tasha: 是这样的
Tasha: Yeah, that's it.
Tasha: 哈哈哈可以这样子的
Tasha: Hahaha, it can be like this.
Tasha: 而且关键是老师一般都不怎么吃
Tasha: And the key thing is, the teacher usually doesn't eat much.
Lucia: 结果都是我吃
Lucia: So I end up eating everything.
Jake: 还打包打了一包回去
Jake: And even packed some to take home.
Jake: 烧烤吗
Jake: Barbecue?
Katrina:  烧烤偏晚上吧
Katrina: Barbecue is more for the evening, right?
Jake: 晚上再吃
Jake: We'll eat it in the evening.
Katrina:  那就是但是你要留他们到晚上的话
Katrina: But if you want them to stay until the evening...
Katrina:  这个晚饭怎么弄
Katrina: How are we going to handle dinner?
Shure:  大家一起烤呗
Shure: Everyone can grill together.
Shure:  一起吃烧烤
Shure: We'll have BBQ together.
Shure:  一起吃这个是吗
Shure: We'll all eat together, right?
Jake: 一起吃什么烧烤的人有点累哦
Jake: Eating BBQ together can be tiring for some people.
Katrina:  因为有20个人左右
Katrina: Because there are about 20 people.
Lucia: 如果来的人多的话
Lucia: If a lot of people come...
Lucia: 就是都烧烤还挺麻麻烦的
Lucia: BBQ can be quite a hassle.
Lucia: 嗯确实而且包饭也麻烦
Lucia: Yeah, and packing meals is troublesome too.
Katrina:  点外卖也麻烦
Katrina: Ordering takeout is a hassle too.
Katrina:  放进去啊
Katrina: Just put it in.
Alice: 就是水流声太大了
Alice: The sound of the water is too loud.
Katrina:  放进去哎
Katrina: Put it in, hey.
Lucia: 对就是可能每人吃那么一两块
Lucia: Yeah, maybe everyone can just have a piece or two.
Lucia: 也不是说要吃的非常饱嘛
Lucia: It's not like we need to eat until we're super full.
Shure:  站点披萨
Shure:  有那个32寸这么大
Shure: There's one that's 32 inches big.
Jake: 那个披萨
Jake: That pizza.
Jake: 行可以弄一张就可以
Jake: Okay, we can just get one.
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Jake: 就到了晚饭的点就摆在这
Jake: Just put it here around dinner time.
Katrina:  对大家饿了自己五点吃
Katrina: Yeah, everyone can eat at 5 if they're hungry.
Jake: 而且如果之前
Jake: And if before...
Lucia: 有
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 吃甜的东西的话可能也不会特别的饿
Lucia: If they had something sweet before, they might not be that hungry.
Katrina:  是的是的
Katrina: Yeah, exactly.
Jake: 那就5点半的时候
Jake: So at 5:30...
Jake: 一个大披萨
Jake: A big pizza.
Katrina:  嗯现在是5点
Katrina: Yeah, it's 5 now.
Katrina:  嗯 5点
Katrina: Yes, 5 o'clock.
Katrina:  那我们的节目就弄到晚上一样
Katrina: Our program will be the same in the evening.
Katrina:  因为我当时想的是
Katrina: Because what I was thinking is...
Katrina:  你那个讲故事的话大家不是很熟
Katrina: If you tell stories, everyone might not be very familiar.
Katrina:  因为你那个讲故事设定在酒吧
Katrina: Because telling stories in a bar setting...
Katrina:  根据酒吧大家都是有故事的人
Katrina: Everyone in a bar has stories.
Katrina:  可能就在那种环境下
Katrina: Maybe in that kind of environment...
Katrina:  然后就愿意讲
Katrina: They are willing to share.
Katrina:  但是我们这种刚过来
Katrina: But for us who just came over...
Katrina:  他们可能不太愿意讲故事
Katrina: They might not want to tell stories.
Katrina:  所以改成自我介绍还挺好
Katrina: So changing it to self-introductions is good.
Katrina:  然后
Katrina: And then...
Katrina:  如果说要讲故事或获金币这个环节
Katrina: If we want to tell stories or win coins, that part...
Katrina:  我觉得可以弄到偏晚上1点
Katrina: I think we can do it around 1 AM.
Katrina:  大家已经熟了一点
Katrina: Everyone will be more familiar.
Katrina:  再加上晚上比较感性
Katrina: Plus, people are more emotional at night.
Katrina:  可以带着一点自己的故事过来
Katrina: They can bring some of their own stories.
Katrina:  然后那
Katrina: Then...
Katrina:  那就5点
Katrina: So at 5...
Katrina:  是他们介绍完他们的pass
Katrina: After they finish introducing their pass...
Katrina:  然后5点到6点就吃烧烤调酒这种吗
Katrina: Then from 5 to 6, we can have BBQ and make cocktails.
Katrina:  其实他并不会完全严格的按照这个
Katrina: Actually, it won't be strictly followed.
Jake: 对所以可以搞个5点到6点的区间
Jake: Yeah, so we can have a 5 to 6 time slot.
Shure:  反正开饭dinner
Shure: Anyway, dinner starts...
Shure:  在5点半之后
Shure: After 5:30.
Shure:  5点半左右嗯
Shure: Around 5:30, yeah.
Jake: 打比赛
Jake: Competition.
Jake: a bow
Jake: A bow.
Jake: 第一个披萨
Jake: The first pizza.
Katrina:  第一个披萨还有BBQ
Katrina: The first pizza also has BBQ.
Shure:  bbq
Shure: BBQ.
Katrina:  那调酒的话是属于贯穿始终
Katrina: And the cocktails are for the whole time.
Shure:  对就像甜品和
Shure: Yeah, just like the desserts and...
Katrina:  甜品就是
Katrina: Desserts are...
Shure: 甜品是desert吧
Shure:  嗯还是SS
Shure: Hmm, or SS.
Shure:  double S是吗
Katrina:  哦你说甜品啊
Katrina: Oh, you mean the desserts?
Shure:  and
Shure: And...
Katrina:  那晚上就还剩啥
Katrina: So, what's left for the evening?
Katrina:  我想想还剩我们的节目
Katrina: Let me think, we still have our show.
Jake: 对我们有
Jake: Yeah, we have...
Katrina:  然后也不能弄太晚
Katrina: And it can't be too late.
Katrina:  他们回去的话要两个小时
Katrina: They need two hours to go back.
Katrina:  嗯那我们就定个结束时间
Katrina: Hmm, let's set an end time.
Jake: 8点可以贯彻始终
Shure: over time at PM
Katrina:  跟戴娜差不多
Katrina: Like Diana, almost.
Katrina:  到6点半
Katrina: Until 6:30 PM.
Katrina:  然后还有一个半小时就是表演
Katrina: And then, an hour and a half for the performance.
Katrina:  表演节目
Katrina: The performance.
Katrina:  能让他们也准备点节目吗
Katrina: Can we ask them to prepare something too?
Katrina:  有没有那种擅长唱歌的
Katrina: Are there any good singers?
Shure:  可以反正我们有把吉他
Katrina:  嗯对
Katrina: Yeah, right.
Katrina:  啊唱唱歌跳跳舞
Katrina: Ah, singing and dancing.
Jake: 对时间太长了
Jake: Yeah, it's a long time.
Jake: 来一个大家一起卡拉OK的环节吧
Jake: Let's have a karaoke session for everyone.
Katrina:  哪个时间太长
Katrina: Which part is too long?
Jake: 不是不是
Jake: No, no.
Jake: 我我我是说中间可能有一个小时
Jake: I mean, there might be an hour in between.
Jake: 我们要传数据
Jake: We need to transfer data.
Jake: 你们的眼镜
Katrina:  陈数军让他们自己逛逛我们的世界
Katrina: Let's have them explore our world.
Katrina:  然后喝点酒
Katrina: And have some drinks.
Katrina:  传数据的时候带大家唱唱歌好了
Shure:  free time在这放一个小电影或者干嘛的
Shure: Let's play a short film or something during the free time.
Alice: 小电影对对对
Alice: A short film, yeah, yeah.
Jake: 中间中间空一个小时差大概
Jake: There's a one-hour gap in between.
Shure:  对当时还说那个就3点什么时候
Shure: Right, back then we said it would be around 3 o'clock.
Shure: 纪录片什么的
Katrina:  那就是那个5点结束之后呗
Katrina: So that would be right after it ends at 5, right?
Jake: 对啊大家吃披萨时候咱就不拍了吧
Jake: 行甜品是什么
Jake: Okay, what's for dessert?
Tasha: 也可以哪个时间段吃甜品
Tasha: We can also have dessert at some other time.
Katrina:  甜品是你就是我
Katrina: Dessert is you, it's me.
Shure: 贯彻始终
Katrina:  不是会得金币吗
Katrina: Isn’t there a way to earn gold coins?
Katrina:  然后3:40到4:20的时候
Katrina: Then from 3:40 to 4:20,
Katrina:  我们介绍我们的产品
Katrina: we introduce our product.
Katrina:  然后我想的是你放在最后
Katrina: And I was thinking you would go last.
Katrina:  然后就是刚好这个part结束了
Katrina: Then when this part ends,
Katrina:  以后大家就可以尝你的甜品
Katrina: everyone can taste your dessert.
Katrina:  4:20 对
Katrina: 4:20, right.
Katrina:  就是你压轴
Katrina: You’re the finale.
Katrina:  哈哈你介绍你的种子片和你的甜品
Katrina: Haha, you introduce your snack and dessert.
Katrina:  我们介绍我们自己做的种
Katrina: We'll introduce the seeds we made.
Jake: 可以嗯
Jake: Sounds good.
Jake: 3点到5点两个小时够
Jake: Two hours from 3 to 5 should be enough.
Jake: 挺好大概从早上就要开始准备
Jake: Great, we should start preparing from the morning.
Tasha: 然后需要配两个人
Tasha: And we need to pair up two people.
Tasha: 可以我可以帮忙
Tasha: I can help.
Katrina:  哈哈哈就想学
Tasha: 哈哈哈配两个人
Shure: 真的起得来吗
Jake: 可以的我今天只是失误
Jake: We can do it, today was just a mistake.
Katrina:  哈哈哈到时候死都没想到
Katrina: Hahaha, at that time, no one will expect it.
Shure:  我听到了你的闹钟
Shure: I heard your alarm clock.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Katrina:  不是你怎么听到
Katrina: How did you hear it?
Katrina:  你不是住一楼吗
Katrina: Don’t you live on the first floor?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  因为咱俩应该就是差不多上上下这种
Shure: Because we are almost directly above and below each other.
Shure:  啊你那个跟我是一样的
Shure: Ah, yours is the same as mine.
Shure:  不过也正常
Shure: But it’s normal.
Lucia: 我我我本科舍友回我早晨定的闹铃
Lucia: My undergrad roommate also woke up to my morning alarm.
Lucia: 我舍友都醒了
Lucia: My roommate woke up,
Lucia: 我自己还没醒自己就听不见
Lucia: but I didn’t wake up myself, I couldn’t hear it.
Shure:  嗯明天定三个
Shure: Hmm, set three alarms for tomorrow.
Katrina:  那就差不多想想啊
Katrina: Well, think about it.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake: 所以那一天的甜品是要当天做
Jake: So, should the dessert be made on the same day?
Jake: 还是可以前一天做
Jake: Or can it be made the day before?
Tasha: 有的需要冷藏的会前一天做
Tasha: Some that need refrigeration can be made the day before.
Tasha: 比如提拉米苏
Tasha: Like tiramisu.
Katrina:  哎其实像那种
Katrina: Actually, for things like that...
Katrina:  就是我看他们那种清补凉那种
Katrina: Like I saw them make that refreshing dessert...
Katrina:  是不是就买点椰奶然后做点圆
Katrina: You just need to buy some coconut milk and make some balls.
Tasha: 清补凉的话那是不是好调一点啊
Tasha: For that refreshing dessert, it's easier to prepare.
Tasha: 也是前一天做好
Tasha: Also made the day before.
Tasha: 然后第二天就直接把原料
Tasha: Then the next day, just use the ingredients...
Tasha: 然后进行一个配就行
Tasha: And mix them.
Tasha: 对对对就是用那个吉利丁片和椰奶
Tasha: Yeah, yeah, just use gelatin sheets and coconut milk.
Tasha: 就可以做
Tasha: That's enough.
Tasha: 好像
Tasha: Seems like.
Katrina:  哦
Katrina: Oh.
Katrina:  我看他们有的那种糖水就是直接椰奶
Katrina: I saw some of those sweet soups, they just use coconut milk...
Katrina:  然后加一点水果
Katrina: And add some fruit.
Katrina:  加一点芋圆就行了
Katrina: And add some taro balls.
Katrina:  感觉那样会不会简单一点
Katrina: Doesn't that seem easier?
Katrina:  就不要做成那种冻不起的那种
Katrina: Just don't make it like the ones that can't solidify.
Katrina:  就不要用那个什么吉利饮片
Katrina: Don't use those gelatin sheets.
Tasha: 那清不了好吃吗
Tasha: Will that still taste good?
Tasha: 你觉得我觉得随便
Tasha: You think? I think it's fine.
Katrina:  就是我感觉会不会简单一点那种吗
Katrina: I just think it might be simpler that way.
Tasha: 他说不要液体不要固体的啊
Tasha: He said it shouldn't be liquid, not solid either.
Katrina:  就是直接就像那种水牛奶一样的
Katrina: Just like those milk drinks.
Katrina:  因为我自己经常喝的糖水
Katrina: Because I often drink sweet soups like that.
Katrina:  我看他们就是一点椰奶啊
Katrina: They just use some coconut milk, mango, and red beans.
Katrina:  然后芒果然后一些那个红豆
Katrina: Mix them and it's done quickly.
Katrina:  就就这样配就很快
Katrina: Yeah, the taro balls might need to be cooked.
Katrina:  嗯就是芋圆可能要熬一下
Katrina: You can buy the coconut jelly fresh.
Katrina:  椰果呢都能现买耶
Katrina: It's up to you, really.
Katrina:  随便看你看你吧
Katrina: Whatever you say goes.
Katrina:  你说什么就是什么
Katrina: Whatever you decide.
Tasha: 你准备了芋圆
Tasha: Did you prepare taro balls?
Tasha: 芋圆我
Tasha: Taro balls, I...
Tasha: 我没有买芋圆材料
Tasha: I didn't buy the ingredients for taro balls.
Katrina:  芋圆是不是可以直接买
Katrina: Can't you just buy taro balls directly?
Katrina:  芋圆也有成品吧
Katrina: There are also ready-made taro balls, right?
Lucia: 嗯对直接买成品
Lucia: Yeah, just buy the ready-made ones.
Katrina:  那我看看
Katrina: Let me take a look.
Katrina:  4:20介绍完以后
Katrina: After the introduction at 4:20,
Katrina:  要有一个品尝甜品的时间
Katrina: we should have some time to taste the desserts.
Katrina:  那是不是要到4点
Katrina: So, should we do it at 4 o'clock?
Katrina:  4:35开始
Katrina: Start at 4:35.
Katrina:  但是我到5点多
Katrina: But then, by around 5,
Katrina:  然后就开始吃晚饭晚饭
Katrina: we’ll start having dinner.
Katrina:  就是gas part之后我们就收眼镜传数据
Katrina: After the gas part, we’ll collect the glasses and transmit the data.
Jake: 对对对然后吃饭就不录
Jake: Yeah, yeah, and we won't record during dinner.
Jake: 吃饭不录
Jake: No recording during dinner.
Jake: 那那晚饭是自己做吗
Jake: Are we cooking dinner ourselves?
Katrina:  晚饭就那个点披萨嘛
Katrina: We'll just order pizza.
Katrina:  然后一些烧烤
Katrina: And some barbecue.
Jake: 烧烤也不能录
Jake: 烧烤把眼镜给烧坏了
Jake: 哦对
Jake: Oh, right.
Katrina:  没事刚好那那一个小时
Katrina: It's fine, just for that one hour.
Katrina:  那你就传数据
Shure: 那就big披萨得了
Jake: 对对
Shure:  BBQ再说
Shure:  barbecue可以咱们咱们这两天自个吃
Shure: We can barbecue ourselves in the next couple of days.
Jake: 哈哈哈什么东西
Jake: Hahaha, what’s that?
Jake: 芭比q自己试试
Jake: Try barbecuing yourself.
Lucia: 那个是烧烤炉吗
Lucia: Is that a barbecue grill?
Lucia: 是的是的
Lucia: Yes, it is.
Alice: 哦还挺大
Jake: 对
Shure:  然后人太多的话
Shure: If there are too many people,
Shure:  芭比q真的不好不好玩
Shure: Barbecuing isn't much fun.
Alice: 特别慢对
Alice: It's really slow, yeah.
Jake: 那就不要芭比q
Jake: Then let's not barbecue.
Jake: 没关系或者给他整两串得了
Jake: It’s okay, or just make a couple of skewers.
Jake: 哈哈哈意思意思
Jake: Hahaha, just for the sake of it.
Shure: 太太寒碜了点吧
Jake: 哈哈哈那是我自己烤的
Jake: Hahaha, I'll grill it myself.
Lucia: 点到点进来然后就自己烤的
Lucia: Order some and then grill it yourself.
Lucia: 说是烤的
Lucia: They said they grilled it.
Shure:  对菜咱们只买碳然后热一下
Shure:  哇哈哈哈好妙啊
Shure: Wahaha, that's so clever!
Jake: 哈哈挺好看的
Jake: Haha, it looks pretty good.
Lucia: 有西餐厅那种圆的那样罩住
Lucia: It's like those round covers at Western restaurants.
Lucia: 要不然话
Lucia: Otherwise,
Lucia: 大家就会发现
Lucia: Everyone would notice
Lucia: 你这个拿出来的时候
Lucia: When you take it out,
Lucia: 就已经是烤好的了哦
Lucia: It's already baked.
Lucia: 然后就这样挡一下
Lucia: Just cover it like this,
Lucia: 然后放在炉上烤一烤
Lucia: Then put it on the grill for a bit,
Lucia: 说是刚烤的
Lucia: Saying it's freshly baked.
Lucia: 哈哈哈是是是
Lucia: Hahaha, yes, yes.
Shure:  太天才了
Shure: That's genius.
Jake: 我们对一分钟考好
Jake: We finish baking in one minute.
Katrina:  那就我们的那个活动就6点半到8点
Katrina: So our event will be from 6:30 to 8:00.
Katrina:  节目唱唱歌跳舞
Katrina: There will be singing and dancing.
Katrina:  一个半小时够了再长弄不下去了
Katrina: An hour and a half is enough, we can't go longer.
Katrina:  free time对大家可以表演一个半小时
Katrina: Free time, everyone can perform for an hour and a half.
Shure:  然后我们可以auction拆出来也行
Shure: Then we can auction, or split it up.
Shure:  就是比如说没进行完有的人没拍
Shure: For example, if we didn't finish, some people didn't bid.
Shure:  拍完然后啊可以继续想分享
Shure: After bidding, they can continue to share.
Katrina:  接着大家自由交换也行也行
Katrina: Then everyone can freely exchange, that's fine too.
Jake: 嗯反正一般等家务已经有了
Jake: Hmm, anyway, we have the usual chores.
Lucia: 那就是5点半开饭然后6点半我要走了
Lucia: So, we start eating at 5:30, and I have to leave by 6:30.
Tasha: 钱没花完怎么办
Tasha: What if we don't spend all the money?
Jake: 什么什么钱没花完
Jake: What, what money isn't spent?
Shure:  就是那个硬币啊
Shure: The coins, you know.
Jake: 硬币在
Shure: 我们要控制好那个通货
Jake: 对对对送俩充电宝吧
Jake: Yeah, yeah, let's give away two power banks.
Jake: 要不送点充电宝
Jake: Or maybe give away some power banks.
Tasha: 这挺好的
Tasha: That's pretty good.
Katrina:  还可以 反正最后一天了
Shure: 确实这个
Katrina:  你是不是也不太
Katrina: Aren't you also not
Jake: 是的是的
Katrina: 抽奖环节
Katrina:  哈哈哈我到时候也可以买一个
Katrina: Hahaha, I might buy one too.
Tasha: 晚会晚会都送充电宝
Tasha: At the evening party, everyone gives out power banks.
Katrina:  我们也是
Katrina: We do too.
Lucia: 我们招聘会也会送充电宝
Lucia: We also give out power banks at our recruitment fair.
Jake: 哦原因找到了是吧
Jake: Oh, I see the reason now, right?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Katrina:  可以那就把充电宝送出去
Katrina: Okay, then let's give away the power banks.
Tasha: 只要来就可以送一个充电宝
Tasha: Just come and you can get a power bank.
Katrina:  看他们手上有
Katrina: Look, they have them in their hands.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
Shure:  没有没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no, no.
Shure:  没有插上
Shure: No, it's not.
Shure:  嗯好这回插上
Shure: Hmm, okay, now it's connected.
Jake: 哎我摸摸
Jake: Let me check.
Jake: 哎呀你这个没电了
Jake: Oh no, it's out of power.
Jake: 已经没了
Jake: It's already dead.
Jake: 你这已经断掉了啊
Jake: It's already disconnected.
Shure: 重新录一下
Jake: 对你你得
Jake: 没关系就是我们重新看一遍时间就行
Jake: It's okay, we'll just check the time again.
Shure: 好了现在好了因为
Lucia: 因为我的亮吗
Lucia: 它亮着呢
Lucia: It's still on.
Jake: 你再重新开一下
Jake: You need to turn it on again.
Shure:  素材丢失
Shure: Lost some footage.
Jake: 稍有丢失问题不大
Jake: It's okay, it's not a big deal.
Katrina:  那你你的那part的东西买了吗
Katrina: Did you buy the stuff for your part?
Lucia: 我们取决于我们要做什么
Lucia: It depends on what we want to do.
Lucia: 我要买水母
Lucia: I want to buy jellyfish.
Lucia: 不是如果要买水母灯
Lucia: No, I mean if we want to buy a jellyfish lamp.
Lucia: 如果要做水母灯的话
Lucia: If we want to make a jellyfish lamp.
Lucia: 大家是想用材料包做还是
Lucia: Do you want to use a DIY kit or...
Lucia: 就是那种循环利用的做
Lucia: Or do you want to use recyclable materials?
Katrina:  什么叫循环利用的做
Katrina: What do you mean by recyclable materials?
Katrina:  就是拿那个
Katrina: Like using...
Lucia: 呃叫什么奶茶盖那种
Lucia: Uh, like those bubble tea lids.
Lucia: 虽然奶茶盖其实我也没做过
Lucia: But I've never made one with bubble tea lids before.
Lucia: 我之前做过材料包
Lucia: I used a DIY kit before.
Lucia: 奶茶盖的话那是不是得买奶茶呀
Lucia: If we use bubble tea lids, don't we need to buy bubble tea?
Lucia: 确实啊我们可以买个奶茶盖哦
Lucia: Actually, we can just buy bubble tea lids.
Jake: 好没问题
Jake: Sure, no problem.
Lucia: 然后它其实材料还蛮简单的
Lucia: The materials are actually pretty simple.
Lucia: 就丝带和串珠这些就行
Lucia: Just ribbons and beads will do.
Katrina:  那可以直接买材料包了
Katrina: Then we can just buy a DIY kit.
Lucia: 买材料包的话好像就没有那种环保的
Lucia: If you buy the material pack, it doesn't seem to be that eco-friendly.
Katrina:  对特别环保的概念体现
Katrina: Right, especially the eco-friendly concept.
Katrina:  那就那就得喝奶茶了哈哈
Katrina: Then we should drink bubble tea, haha.
Lucia: 或者也可以
Lucia: Or we could...
Lucia: 应该应该
Lucia: It should, it should...
Lucia: 淘宝上有那种包装
Lucia: There are those kinds of packages on Taobao.
Lucia: 也可以买一个我看看
Lucia: You can also buy one, let me check.
Katrina:  但是你买包装跟买材料包感觉差不多
Katrina: But buying the package feels almost the same as buying the material pack.
Katrina:  意思确实
Katrina: That’s true.
Lucia: 但是就是
Lucia: But, it's just...
Lucia: 至少它给人的视觉效果是环保的
Lucia: At least it gives the visual effect of being eco-friendly.
Lucia: 至于它流
Lucia: As for its flow...
Lucia: 程中这个就我们自行控制
Lucia: During the process, we can control it ourselves.
Katrina:  那应该没啥问题了
Katrina: That shouldn't be a problem then.
Katrina:  然后可能嗯
Katrina: And then maybe, um...
Katrina:  如果要唱歌那种音响话筒这音调节
Katrina: If we need to sing, the sound system and microphone need to be adjusted.
Jake: 我们之前让GPT出了几个plan
Jake: We previously asked GPT to come up with a few plans.
Jake: 嗯嗯嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Shure:  比如
Jake:环保版
Jake: 你你说你画我猜
Jake: You mean the drawing game?
Jake: 啊这个是参与者
Jake: Ah, this involves participants.
Katrina:  可以设置参与者分组
Katrina: We can set participant groups.
Jake: 每组选择一个环保词汇
Jake: Each group selects an eco-friendly term.
Jake: 如太阳能
Jake: Like solar energy.
Jake: 零废弃
Jake: 啊还可以吧
Jake: Ah, that works too.
Tasha: 还不错该怎么表达
Tasha: Not bad, how should we express it?
Shure:  就是这种特别抽象的
Shure: It's really abstract.
Shure:  然后大家就不好画
Shure: So it's hard for everyone to draw.
Shure:  只能画吗
Shure: Can we only draw?
Lucia: 不能描述吗
Lucia: Can’t we describe it?
Jake: 画画
Jake: Drawing.
Jake: 对啊不能说话了
Jake: Yeah, no talking allowed.
Jake: 还有嗯
Jake: Also, um...
Katrina:  那就设置在晚上吧
Katrina: Let’s set it for the evening then.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Sure.
Katrina:  下午的时间不是很多
Katrina: There’s not much time in the afternoon.
Katrina:  下午3点开始到5点半
Katrina: Start at 3 PM and end at 5:30 PM.
Katrina:  就两个半小时
Katrina: Just two and a half hours.
Katrina:  介绍介绍
Katrina: Let me introduce...
Katrina:  逛一逛就差不多了
Katrina: Just wandering around should be enough.
Jake: 嗯还有一个更离谱的
Jake: Yeah, there's something even more ridiculous.
Jake: 他的GPT确实厉害
Jake: His GPT is really impressive.
Jake: 在沙盘或沙地中
Jake: In the sandbox or sandpit,
Jake: 隐藏一些微型塑料颗粒
Jake: he hides some tiny plastic particles.
Jake: 参与者使用镊子和放大镜
Jake: Participants use tweezers and magnifying glasses
Jake: 在规定时间内
Jake: to find as many of these plastic particles
Jake: 尽可能找出这些塑料颗粒
Jake: as possible within a set time.
Jake: 这个游戏
Jake: This game...
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake: 这个游戏
Jake: This game...
Jake: 可以让大家直观的认识到
Jake: allows people to directly understand
Jake: 微塑料污染的隐蔽性
Jake: the hidden nature of microplastic pollution.
Jake: 哈哈哈很妙
Jake: Haha, it's quite clever.
Jake: 这个GPT就是使唤人
Jake: This GPT just commands people.
Jake: AI使唤人挺能整
Jake: AI commanding people, it's quite something.
Shure:  完了你可不能向她学听没听到
Katrina: 感觉是一种变向的寻宝
Katrina: Feels like a sort of treasure hunt.
Lucia: 寻废品
Lucia: Searching for junk.
Jake: 而且你这个头发还是遮住了
Jake: And your hair is still covering it.
Jake: 要不还是我们
Jake: How about we...
Jake: 我们下午下午采购一波
Jake: We do some shopping this afternoon.
Jake: 采购一波
Jake: Go for a shopping spree.
Shure:  采购一波对发卡
Katrina:  下午要去采购是吗
Katrina: Are we going shopping this afternoon?
Tasha: 嗯这个吗
Tasha: Hmm, for this?
Shure:  对就是这种
Shure:  这种小别的那种
Shure: These small things.
Jake: 我们再看一圈吧
Jake: Let's take another look around.
Jake: 我们其实不用
Jake: We actually don't need to,
Jake: 但是也看一眼
Jake: but let's have a look anyway.
Lucia: 哎停住了
Lucia: Hey, it stopped.
Jake: 哎呀完了
Jake: Oh no, it's over.
Jake: 没事
Jake: It's okay.
Jake: 我们其实剩下的一个人就行
Jake: Actually, we just need one more person.
Jake: 但是就转一圈比较稳妥
Jake: But it's safer to look around once more.
Katrina:  我发现这名片好好看
Katrina: I found this business card really beautiful.
Shure:  哦你们看那个你想活出怎样的人生
Shure: Oh, did you guys see "How Do You Live?"
Shure:  宫崎骏的那个
Shure: The one by Hayao Miyazaki.
Katrina:  看没看懂
Katrina: Did you understand it?
Katrina:  后来看解析
Katrina: And then I looked at the analysis.
Katrina:  回来看解析
Katrina: Came back to look at the analysis.
Katrina:  应该先看解析再去看
Katrina: Probably should have looked at the analysis first.
Shure:  那些数字
Shure: Those numbers.
Alice: 他只有5%的电正充着电
Alice: His battery is only at 5%, it's charging.
Alice: 他不会充的没用的快吧
Alice: It won't charge fast enough to be useful.
Shure:  呃不会的
Jake: 不会不会不会
Shure:  你要保证它紧了就可以
Katrina:  对OK那这就差不多敲定了
Katrina: Right, OK, I think we almost have it settled.
Jake: 差不多了那我们看看要准备什么吧
Jake: Almost, now let's see what we need to prepare.
Jake: 这几天
Jake: In the next few days.
Katrina:  嗯我想想啊就是各自买各自的材料
Katrina: Hmm, let me think. We each buy our own materials.
Katrina:  然后
Katrina: And then...
Katrina:  然后要有音响和话筒如果要唱歌的话
Katrina: And then we need speakers and microphones if we want to sing.
Shure:  这个我都能搞定
Shure: I can take care of that.
Katrina:  例外啊你本来就乐队的是吧
Katrina: Of course, you're already in a band, right?
Jake: 啊你可以把音乐队都给弄来
Jake: Ah, you can bring the whole band in.
Katrina:  我们当时就也总是那乐队同学带音响
Katrina: Back then, our bandmates always brought the speakers.
Shure:  这这算商演吧应该
Shure: This would count as a commercial performance, right?
Katrina:  商演商演商演
Katrina: Commercial performance, commercial performance.
Jake: 学术商演学术商演
Shure: 学术商演
Jake: 在学术会议上面商演演唱会算什么呀
Jake: What does a concert at an academic conference even mean?
Jake: 你们接过这种活吗
Jake: Have you ever taken such gigs?
Jake:哦没去
Jake: Oh, didn't go.
Shure:  之前邀邀请过但是没没去
Shure: Got invited before, but didn't go.
Shure:  有点太尴尬了主要是
Shure: It was too awkward, mainly.
Jake: 哦这下面人在看pose呢
Jake: Oh, people below are watching the pose.
Jake: 然后你在这瞅我
Jake: And you're just staring at me.
Shure:  对对啊多尬呀我靠
Shure: Yeah, it's so awkward, damn.
Katrina:  他那个呃你们买了什么
Katrina: What did you guys buy?
Katrina:  支架和小桌子吗
Katrina: A stand and a small table?
Jake: 嗯我们要不看看快递
Jake: Hmm, should we check the delivery?
Jake: 或者我们到处看一看吧
Jake: Or should we look around?
Jake: 我们
Jake: We...
Jake: 因为这个房间我们可能也要收拾收拾
Jake: Because we might need to tidy up this room.
Jake: 装饰装饰
Jake: Decorate it.
Jake:这个
Jake: This...
Katrina:  哦那我们是不是
Katrina: Oh, so should we...
Katrina:  如果你要世界地球日为主题
Katrina: If you want the theme to be Earth Day.
Katrina:  要买一点贴画呀
Katrina: Should we buy some stickers?
Jake: 对对对是的
Jake: Yes, yes, that's right.
Jake: 但是这个墙不能贴
Jake: But we can't stick anything on this wall.
Jake: 我们也得想想办法怎么搞
Jake: We need to figure out a way to do it.
Katrina:  有那种无痕贴的挂钩
Katrina: There are those hooks that don't leave marks.
Jake: 就是他就不不能贴这种墙
Jake: But they can't stick to this kind of wall.
Katrina:  我知道
Katrina: I know.
Katrina:  我姐结婚的时候他们就是那种贴的
Katrina: My sister used those when she got married.
Katrina:  就是酒店贴的
Katrina: The hotel used them.
Katrina:  可以撕下来就完全无痕的
Katrina: You can peel them off without any marks.
Jake: OK如果很稳妥的话可以不然的话赔钱
Jake: OK, if they're really secure. Otherwise, we'll have to pay for damages.
Jake: 哈哈哈对这样看了
Jake: Haha, yeah, we'll see.
Katrina:  然后还有就是我们每个人的东西的话
Katrina: And also, for each of our items...
Katrina:  他的甜品有自己的甜品家
Katrina: His desserts have their own stand.
Katrina:  那我们每个人
Katrina: So for each of us...
Katrina:  东西是不是也要有装桌子摆摊
Katrina: Should our items also have a table setup?
Jake: 嗯可以
Jake: Yeah, that works.
Katrina:  因为那天呃
Katrina: Because that day, uh...
Shure: 去宜家采购一波吧
Shure: Let's go on a shopping spree at IKEA.
Shure:  20多人哈哈哈
Shure: With over 20 people, haha.
Jake:过分了
Lucia: 直接给别墅主人添新家具
Alice: 一个够吗
Alice: Is one enough?
Alice: 还是要多买两个
Alice: Or do we need to buy two more?
Katrina:  你这一个是就是多少人可以一起玩
Katrina: How many people can play with just one of these?
Shure:  大概就一个人一起玩
Shure: Probably just one person.
Lucia: 哈哈哈两三个应该也行
Lucia: Haha, maybe two or three could manage.
Lucia: 再多是不是可能
Lucia: Any more than that might be difficult.
Shure:  其实买3个差不多
Jake: 我们要不玩一下
Jake: Why don't we try it out?
Jake: 怎么玩
Jake: How do we play?
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 我们先来试验一下
Lucia: Let's test it out first.
Jake:直接做个实验先
Jake: Let's do an experiment first.
Shure:  我们这些这些都得试验一遍
Shure: We need to test all of these.
Shure:  就是彩排甜品我们得先先吃一遍
Shure: We should rehearse the desserts and taste them first.
Shure:  然后烧烤也得先吃一遍
Shure: Also, we should taste the BBQ first.
Lucia: 算盘打的
Lucia: Clever plan.
Alice: 这是一个支架的就不用管它
Alice: This one has a stand, so we don't need to worry about it.
Shure:  毕竟其实这个比点外卖会便宜一些
Shure: Actually, this is cheaper than ordering takeout.
Tasha: 什么会比点外卖便宜什么东西
Tasha: What is cheaper than takeout? What are you talking about?
Shure:  就是比如说自己搞顿烧烤
Shure: For example, like doing a barbecue yourself
Shure:  比点一桌子这样的烤串肯定会便宜
Shure: It's definitely cheaper than ordering a whole table of skewers
Jake: 嗯那是这烧烤卖的可贵了
Jake: Yeah, that's true. Barbecue here is really expensive
Shure:  一个是一串四五块钱哦
Shure: Each skewer costs like four or five bucks
Alice: 啊挺多
Alice: Wow, that's a lot
Jake: 哦看起来很难拼到吧
Jake: Oh, it looks hard to put together, right?
Alice: 确实不太好拼比较费时间
Alice: Yeah, it's not easy to piece together, it's time-consuming
Tasha: 要怎么拼
Tasha: How do you put it together?
Jake: 就把它给拼成一个圆啊
Jake: Just fit it into a circle
Jake: 你要fit进去边缘
Jake: You have to fit it into the edges
Shure:  这种弧形的都应该在边边
Shure: These curved pieces should be on the edge
Jake: 他有可能骗你的吧
Jake: He might be tricking you
Jake: 有会有可能吧
Jake: It's possible, right?
Tasha: 哎你这个明显就不在边边你这个
Tasha: Hey, this one clearly isn't on the edge
Tasha: 不对这样不对
Tasha: No, this isn't right
Jake: 一个都找不到
Jake: Can't find a single one
Lucia: 这个应该是在边边的这个
Lucia: This one should be on the edge
Lucia: 这个部分
Lucia: This part
Shure:  对一个边是在边边的
Shure: Yeah, one side should be on the edge
Shure: 这个好像找不到了
Shure: This one seems impossible to find
Lucia: 这个好像也能贴上
Lucia: This one might also fit
Shure:  这不完全OK
Shure: This isn't completely okay
Jake: 他是一定会完全还是他他就会
Jake: Should it fit perfectly, or will it just...
Katrina:  这个很适合放在安全性那边
Katrina: This one is perfect for the safety section
Katrina:  让大家熟悉起来
Katrina: So everyone gets familiar with it
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Katrina:  这几个人坐在一起
Katrina: These people sitting together
Jake: 有那种特别大的玩一把
Jake: There's a really big one you can play with
Katrina:  就是没有很大的就是很有可能这样
Katrina: There's no big one, it's likely like this
Shure:  哎呦是吧
Shure: Oh, right
Shure:  屌的嘞哈哈哈
Shure: Awesome, haha
Lucia: 感觉应该是看起来很
Lucia: It looks like it should fit well
Lucia: 就是密合程度是比较高的嗯
Lucia: The degree of fit is quite high, yeah
Lucia: 那这个就是哎有可能
Lucia: So this one, hmm, it might
Shure: 这个在这呢
Shure: 洒洒水啊
Tasha: 天才三位天才
Shure:  这不两分钟搞定啊哈哈哈
Shure: Didn't you finish it in two minutes, haha
Lucia: 这里是缺一个
Shure: 谁的脚比较啊
Alice: 哦不是完全拼合的
Alice: Oh, it's not completely fitting
Alice: 还是有一点点缝缝的
Alice: There's still a tiny gap
Alice: 不对看一下答案吗
Alice: Should we check the answer?
Shure:  不需要不需要
Alice:就是你也记不住啊
Jake: 没有没有我们能拼出来
Jake: No, no, we can figure it out.
Jake: 能拼出来
Jake: We can figure it out.
Shure:  哈哈哈我们看答案
Shure: Hahaha, let's check the answers.
Shure:  开什么玩笑
Shure: What a joke.
Lucia: 我觉得这个
Lucia: 这个游戏参与度还是很高的
Lucia: This game is really engaging.
Alice: 反正你也记不住
Alice: Anyway, you won't remember.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我刚刚看到了跟他很像的在这里嗯
Lucia: I just saw something that looks quite similar here, hmm.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Katrina:  嵌不进去差一点点
Katrina: It doesn't fit, just a bit off.
Jake: 嗯怎么一个靠谱的都找不到呢
Jake: Hmm, why can't we find a reliable one?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 这算吗这个
Jake: Does this count?
Katrina: 不是严丝合缝
Katrina: It's not a perfect fit.
Lucia: 这个这俩看起来挺像的诶
Lucia: These two look quite similar.
Jake: 这是不是
Jake: Is this...
Jake: 对他不是严丝合缝
Jake: Right, it's not a perfect fit.
Katrina:  但是如果严丝合缝就很好找啊
Katrina: But if it were a perfect fit, it would be easy to find.
Katrina:  找那个不同的
Katrina: Find the different one.
Jake:他有可能有很多解法
Jake: It might have many solutions.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Jake: 毫无头绪
Jake: No clue at all.
Jake: 这可能就啥也没有啊
Jake: There might be nothing at all.
Jake: 逗你玩
Jake: Just messing with you.
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Tasha: 我觉得都没有一圈怎么回事
Tasha: I feel like we're missing a whole circle, what's going on?
Jake: 对啊他面积都不够啊
Jake: Yeah, it's not big enough.
Jake: 对我们要不直接往里面放吧
Jake: Let's just put it in directly.
Jake: 你看能不能完了
Jake: See if it works.
Shure:  哈哈哈急了有人急了
Shure: Hahaha, someone's getting anxious.
Jake: 哈哈哈不是不是不是不是
Jake: Hahaha, no, no, no, no.
Jake:往里面放放看
Jake: Just put it in and see.
Lucia: 看起来就是
Lucia: It looks like...
Lucia: 这还有一些就感觉可能是差不多的
Lucia: There are some that seem to be quite similar.
Lucia: 哎这是猫头鹰
Lucia: Oh, it's an owl.
Lucia: 好可爱哦
Lucia: So cute.
Shure:  有人急了呀
Shure: Someone's getting anxious.
Alice: 这样看起来几个人一起玩也可以
Alice: It looks like a few people can play together.
Jake: 是的是的挺好的这个东西
Jake: Yes, yes, it's pretty good, this thing.
Shure:  这也不是严丝合缝
Shure: It's not a perfect fit.
Lucia: 好难哦
Lucia: So difficult.
Jake: 是什么东西
Jake: What is this thing?
Lucia: 哈哈哈是小老鼠吗
Lucia: Hahaha, is it a little mouse?
Lucia: 青蛙
Lucia: Frog.
Katrina: 土地公公
Katrina: Earth God.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈咱们是野生动物
Shure: Hahaha, we're wild animals.
Lucia: 土地公公哈哈哈
Lucia: Earth God, hahaha.
Shure:  不是神话故事
Shure: It's not a myth.
Shure:  还土地公公
Shure: Earth God, really?
Jake: 野生神仙
Jake: Wild fairy.
Lucia: 野生
Lucia: Wild.
Katrina:  特别像一个表情包
Katrina: Looks just like an emoji.
Jake:没有
Jake: No.
Alice: 怎么又不亮了
Alice: Why isn't it lighting up again?
Jake: 我看一下
Jake: Let me see.
Shure: 是那边没插上
Shure: It's not plugged in over there.
Lucia: 奇怪
Lucia: Strange.
Alice: 但是他一直
Alice: But it always...
Alice: 是35的电
Alice: It was at 35% power.
Alice: 不好意思
Alice: Sorry.
Alice: 就没有嗯
Alice: It just didn't, um...
Katrina:  我也是一直35
Katrina: Mine was always at 35% too.
Jake: 对他电很多
Jake: Yes, it has a lot of power.
Jake: 嗯不是
Jake: Hmm, no.
Shure:  他是一个2万毫安
Shure: It's a 20,000 mAh battery.
Jake: 是我看一下你的这个APP
Jake: Let me see your app.
Tasha: 我觉得这个是这样子
Tasha: I think it's like this.
Katrina:  就是那软件吗对
Katrina: Is it that software? Yes.
Tasha: 这个是不是这样子
Tasha: Is it like this?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Alice:但是他显示在记录
Alice: But it's showing as recording.
Jake: 插进去就对了
Jake: Just plug it in.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 我看一下看一下
Jake: Let me check.
Jake: 你是l你是L2是吗
Jake: Are you L2?
Jake: 灯坏了呵呵呵
Jake: The light is broken, hahaha.
Alice: 他在录但是
Alice: It's recording, but...
Lucia: 他是就是是不是自动
Lucia: Is it automatic?
Lucia: 自动监测
Lucia: Automatic monitoring.
Lucia: 觉得现在这个环境不需要开灯
Lucia: It thinks there's no need to turn on the light in this environment.
Jake: 没有不是不是不是这个
Jake: No, no, no, that's not it.
Lucia: 提示你被录呢
Lucia: It's notifying you that you're being recorded.
Jake: 这个是为了保护被拍摄人的隐私啊
Jake: This is to protect the privacy of the person being filmed.
Jake: 被拍摄人知道自己
Jake: So the person being filmed knows.
Lucia: 对对对哦OK
Lucia: Yes, yes, oh OK.
Jake: 但是其实拍摄人不知道
Jake: But actually the person filming doesn't know.
Jake: 但是呵呵
Jake: But hehe.
Jake: 拍摄人应该会感觉到吧
Lucia: 啊了胜于无
Lucia: Better than nothing.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 再输一下
Jake: Let's try again.
Jake: 他
Jake: He...
Jake: 刚刚其实是软件没有更新你的状态
Jake: Actually, the software didn't update your status earlier.
Jake: 所以你是没有在录
Jake: So you weren't recording.
Jake: 但是软件上也是我在录
Jake: But on the software, it showed I was recording.
Jake: 所以这
Jake: So this...
Alice:我按照现在的时间吗
Lucia: 这个到底是什么
Lucia: What is this exactly?
Lucia: 还有5个角哎
Lucia: It has five corners!
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Yeah, that's right.
Jake: 你按照现在的事情
Jake: Just follow the current steps.
Lucia: 神奇
Lucia: Amazing.
Shure: 就是蛤蟆
Shure: It's just a toad.
Jake: 哈哈哈估计最后才能放吧
Jake: Haha, I guess we can only release it at the end.
Jake:这个
Jake: This one.
Jake: 这是大嘴鸟是吧
Jake: This is a toucan, right?
Tasha: 哦我靠
Tasha: Oh my gosh.
Lucia: 好抽象啊
Lucia: So abstract.
Jake: 大嘴鸟
Jake: A toucan.
Jake: 这个也很抽象
Jake: This one is also very abstract.
Jake: 谁家牛长这样
Jake: Whose cow looks like this?
Shure:  野牛啊水牛
Shure: A wild ox or a buffalo.
Jake: 那水牛为什么下面会长稻草
Jake: Why does this buffalo have straw underneath?
Alice: 他站在草上
Alice: It's standing on grass.
Shure:  毛很长这个这个
Shure: Its hair is really long, this one, this one.
Lucia: 是不是他这一边
Lucia: Is it on this side?
Lucia: 是哎对
Lucia: Yes, it is.
Shure:  他叫牦牛
Shure: It's called a yak.
Jake: 对这个很妙
Jake: Yeah, it's pretty cool.
Jake: 嗯这个太妙了
Jake: Hmm, this is brilliant.
Lucia: 然后既然是这一边的话
Lucia: And since it's on this side,
Lucia: 那这里应该有一个能放的东西
Lucia: There should be something that can fit here.
Alice: 尖尖的
Alice: Something pointy.
Lucia: 好像不是耶
Lucia: Seems like it's not.
Lucia: 不是呢
Lucia: Nope, it's not.
Shure:  CPU干烧了
Shure:  AI快给我一个解法
Shure: AI, give me a solution quickly.
Jake: 大家一直在看时间
Jake: Everyone's been watching the time.
Jake: 看秒表这个数据
Jake: Watching the stopwatch data.
Katrina:  看这个是为了干啥
Katrina: What's the point of watching this?
Jake: 为了同步
Jake: For synchronization.
Jake: 回头就是在某一个帧上面把时间写上
Jake: Later, we just write the time on a specific frame.
Jake: 哦明白了
Jake: Oh, I get it.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey.
Lucia: 好难哦
Lucia: This is so hard.
Jake: 这个会在边上吗
Jake: Will this be on the side?
Jake: 还有没有边了
Jake: Is there any edge left?
Lucia: 这个边怎么给人一种不太够的感觉
Lucia: Why does this edge feel a bit insufficient?
Alice: 他这不是严丝合缝
Alice: It's not a perfect fit.
Alice: 有的是差不多的那种
Alice: Some are just approximate.
Alice: 嗯这回是比较不太像
Alice: Hmm, this time it's quite different.
Jake: 要不还是全放进去吧
Jake: How about we just put everything in?
Jake: 哈哈全放进去
Jake: Haha, put everything in.
Jake: 先看一看他乱拼的话差多少
Jake: Let's first see how much it mismatches if we just randomly put them together.
Tasha: 这只鸟好占位置
Tasha: This bird takes up so much space.
Katrina:  所有的都可以放进去
Katrina: Everything can fit in.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yes.
Shure:  我感觉它比那个大呢总面积
Tasha: 不是
Tasha: No.
Tasha: 那就塞个你
Tasha: Then just stuff you in.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 你塞不进去换一个
Tasha: If you can't fit, change to another.
Tasha: 你也塞不进去
Tasha: You can't fit either.
Katrina:  我们塞他
Katrina: Let's stuff him.
Lucia: 这啥这是刺猬吗
Lucia: What's this, a hedgehog?
Alice: 哈哈可以
Alice: Haha, it's possible.
Tasha: 他肯定就在这了
Tasha: It must be here.
Lucia: 哦就是我以为他是太阳公公的胯下
Lucia: Oh, I thought it was under the Sun God's crotch.
Tasha: 土地公公的胯下
Tasha: Under the crotch of the land god
Lucia: 看哈哈哈像不像太阳
Lucia: Look, hahaha, doesn't it look like the sun?
Shure: 流氓
Shure: Pervert
Lucia: 我觉得这个太阳应该很好找到对应的
Lucia: I think this sun should be easy to find a match for
Lucia: 就因为他这里有很多的刺
Lucia: Because it has a lot of spikes here
Jake:这边
Jake: Over here
Lucia: 所以我觉得这个是这个特别像耶
Lucia: So I think this one looks a lot like it
Jake: 哇这个这个太严格了吧
Jake: Wow, this is too strict
Lucia: 耶
Lucia: Yay
Jake: 我去
Jake: Oh my
Jake: 这太严格了
Jake: This is too strict
Jake: 如果都是这种严格程度的话
Jake: If everything is this strict
Jake: 那就好找了
Jake: Then it will be easy to find
Lucia: 胜利又顺利找到一个
Lucia: Victory! We found another one
Alice: 谁没家
Alice: Who's homeless?
Shure:  如今你四海为家
Shure: Nowadays, you're at home everywhere
Tasha: 怎么办还有这么多人没有家
Tasha: What to do, so many people are homeless
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Alright
Shure:  回家回家
Shure: Go home, go home
Shure:  回家是最好的礼物
Shure: Home is the best gift
Jake: 放BGM吧要不
Jake: Let's play some BGM
Jake: BGM再继续进去
Jake: Continue with the BGM
Shure:  这时候应该放这个
Shure: We should play this now
Alice: 怎么办是不是标注一下
Alice: What to do, should we tag it?
Alice: 为什么这时候要放这个
Alice: Why play this now?
Alice: 好像真的是在这的
Alice: Seems like it's really here
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Alice:是吧
Alice: Right?
Jake: 嗯很难很难说
Jake: Hmm, hard to say
Alice: 好吧不是
Alice: Okay, maybe not
Lucia: 能让AI把这些轮廓都扫描一下
Lucia: Can we let AI scan all these outlines?
Lucia: 然后让他帮忙拼吗
Lucia: And then let it help us piece it together?
Jake: 嗯试试
Jake: Hmm, let's try
Alice: 无限次试
Alice: Try infinitely
Alice: 对反正他算的快
Alice: Yeah, it calculates fast anyway
Lucia: 对就是应该有这种类似的软件吧
Lucia: Yes, there should be similar software for this
Lucia: 不然就是那种乐高都是怎么设计的
Lucia: Otherwise, how do they design those Legos?
Jake: 对
Jake: Right
Alice: 动物世界
Alice: Animal World
Alice: 哈哈哈这个应该是这样子的吧
Alice: Hahaha, it should be like this, right?
Tasha: 哈哈哈哎
Tasha: Hahaha, hey!
Lucia: 很像很像
Lucia: Looks so much like it.
Lucia: 应该是的
Lucia: It probably is.
Lucia: 嗯好厉害
Lucia: Mmm, so impressive.
Tasha: 他们俩捆绑了
Tasha: They’re tied up together.
Tasha: 对就是把
Tasha: Yeah, just like...
Lucia: 只要把那
Lucia: As long as...
Lucia: 个能合上的都放在一起先
Lucia: 然后再看他们具体是个怎么回事吧
Lucia: Then we'll see what's going on with them specifically.
Tasha: 把不对的拿出来
Lucia: 对对
Alice: 他俩是不是
Alice: Are they two...
Alice: 这个肯定在边上
Alice: This one definitely goes on the side.
Lucia: 所以这个也可以这样放一下他仨
Lucia: So this can be placed like this with those three.
Lucia: 但是这他这个这么明显
Lucia: But this one is so obvious.
Lucia: 应该会有一个
Lucia: There should be one more.
Alice: 他俩像不像一家的感觉
Alice: Don't they look like they belong to the same family?
Alice: 是一家的他们俩像一家的
Alice: They look like they're from the same family.
Tasha: 他就没有那么一家他
Tasha: He doesn't seem like he's from the same family.
Alice: 这样子吧
Alice: Like this?
Tasha: 中间能不能再塞一条东西这个
Tasha: Can we stuff something in the middle here?
Lucia: 是不是有点像啊
Lucia: Doesn't it look a bit like that?
Jake: 反过来不至于
Jake: Not necessarily if you flip it.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice: 或者在这里面谁是条条的
Alice: Or maybe someone here is doing it piece by piece?
Tasha: 他他不一定对
Tasha: He, he might not be right.
Tasha: 他拿走这这些小家伙都不对
Tasha: He took these little guys, and it's not right.
Lucia: 这个有有谁是长成这样的
Lucia: Does anyone look like this?
Shure:  这样吗可以这个样子哦
Shure: Like this? Is this okay?
Shure:  在中间留着一点
Shure: Leave a bit in the middle.
Shure:  然后这样哦
Shure: And then like this.
Lucia: 有道理就可以
Lucia: Makes sense, that works.
Lucia: 看这个和这两边感觉就比较哎
Lucia: Look, this and these two sides feel just about right.
Tasha: 我刚刚找的那个呢
Tasha: Where's the one I just found?
Tasha: 哦不是
Tasha: Oh, no.
Tasha: 我还找了一个呢
Tasha: I found another one.
Alice: 我把它拆了
Alice: I took it apart.
Alice: 拆成他俩了
Alice: Split it into two.
Alice: 就你刚刚说的是这个吧行哦
Alice: You were talking about this one earlier, right? Okay.
Tasha: 他又在上去存疑
Tasha: He's going back up to be questioned.
Lucia: 完了咱他俩这么长时间都没拼出来
Lucia: We've spent so much time and still haven't figured it out.
Lucia: 要是放到下午大家拼可能也拼不出来
Lucia: If we leave it till the afternoon, everyone might still not figure it out.
Katrina:  让他们玩一下午吧对
Katrina: Let them play with it all afternoon, yeah.
Katrina:  这拼出来了给多少金币
Katrina: How many gold coins do they get if they figure it out?
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Tasha: 这个为什么在摸他的屁股
Tasha: Why is this one touching his butt?
Tasha: 然后这个蹲在他的屁股上
Tasha: And this one's squatting on his butt.
Tasha: 哈哈哈你是来拉屎的吧
Tasha: 哈哈哈真的是这样放的吗
Tasha: Hahaha, is this really how you put it?
Tasha: 哈哈也可能不是
Tasha: Haha, maybe not.
Shure:  这绝对不是
Shure: Definitely not.
Shure:  太变态了
Shure: That's too weird.
Tasha: 好了只有目前这些是确定的
Tasha: Alright, that's all we know for now.
Lucia: 好难
Lucia: So hard.
Alice: 他的这个脚肯定
Alice: His foot definitely...
Lucia: 嗯不太可能
Lucia: Hmm, not likely.
Shure:  这个脚肯定插到谁的屁股里
Shure: His foot must have ended up in someone's butt.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 这个在这的
Tasha: This is right here.
Alice: 他揭着他的屁股好
Alice: He's covering his butt.
Alice: 好尴尬
Alice: So awkward.
Tasha: 刚刚谁说他是土地公公的
Tasha: Who just said he was the Earth God?
Alice: 哎这两个是不是可以在一起哇
Alice: Hey, can these two be together?
Lucia: 好了
Lucia: Alright.
Lucia: 好了哇
Lucia: Yeah, alright.
Alice: 再来一个
Alice: One more time.
Alice: 好厉害
Alice: So impressive.
Lucia: 感觉胜利在望了
Lucia: Feels like victory is near.
Tasha: 三人游戏
Tasha: Three-player game.
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Alright, alright.
Katrina:  这是个什么
Katrina: What's this?
Lucia: 这是个猴子吧
Lucia: Is this a monkey?
Jake: 好像哦是的
Jake: Looks like it, yeah.
Alice: 哎这样也挺挺搭的
Alice: Hey, this actually fits well.
Jake: 像吗哎
Jake: Really?
Jake: 好像一般像吧
Jake: Kind of, yeah.
Tasha: 一般吧
Jake:有可能吧
Jake: 像吗一般像一般像
Jake: Does it look like it? Kind of, yeah.
Tasha: 两个细长条形的
Tasha: Two long thin strips.
Jake: 这片头多久啊
Jake: How long is this intro?
Jake: 几分钟刚刚的
Jake: Just a few minutes ago.
Jake: 动物世界
Jake: Animal World.
Shure: 4分32秒
Shure: 4 minutes and 32 seconds.
Tasha: 哈哈什么东西
Tasha: Haha, what is that?
Jake: 刚刚那个动物世界
Jake: That Animal World from earlier.
Jake: 4分32秒已经悄悄的过去了
Jake: 4 minutes and 32 seconds have already quietly passed.
Tasha: 才过去4分钟吗
Tasha: Only 4 minutes have passed?
Tasha: 嗯哈哈
Tasha: Hmm haha.
Jake: 还好还好
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Lucia: 怎么觉得这个弧形边完全找不全对
Lucia: Why does it feel like this curved edge can't be matched?
Jake:对
Tasha: 所以
Tasha: So...
Tasha: 这个算是反了
Tasha: This part is reversed.
Alice: 是吧哎
Alice: Right?
Alice: 反了吧没反
Alice: Reversed or not?
Alice: 嗯就这颜色
Alice: Hmm, it's just this color.
Tasha: 我不想
Tasha: I don't want to...
Tasha: 哎你刚不是把那个放在一起了吗
Tasha: Hey, didn't you just put that together?
Alice: 疑似
Alice: Maybe.
Alice: 也不像
Alice: Doesn't look like it.
Lucia: 他到底是哪一边
Lucia: Which side is it on?
Alice: 他是来迷惑你的
Alice: It's here to confuse you.
Lucia: 感觉两个好像都可以
Lucia: Feels like both sides could work.
Tasha: 不太像这么大啊
Tasha: Doesn't seem to be this big.
Shure:  血压高了怎么办
Shure: What if my blood pressure goes up?
Lucia: 哎会是这样的
Lucia: Oh, it could be like that.
Jake: 嗯嗯
Jake: Hmm hmm.
Tasha: 这个是在这个边边上吗
Tasha: Is this at the edge?
Tasha: 这个是在边边上
Tasha: This is at the edge.
Lucia: 这样贴着
Lucia: Like this, stick it on.
Jake: 拆快递吧
Jake: Let's open the package.
Jake: 要不哈哈
Jake: Or haha.
Jake: 啊拆快递拆快递拆快递拆快递
Jake: Ah, open the package, open the package, open the package.
Katrina:  我去把我的花
Katrina: I'll go get my flowers.
Shure: 不行了
Shure: Can't do it anymore.
Shure:  血压高了
Shure: Blood pressure's up.
Alice: 怎么怎么回事
Alice: What's going on?
Jake: 拆拆一会回来
Jake: Open it, I'll be back in a bit.
Jake: 呃呃就有灵感了
Jake: Uh, I just got inspired.
Tasha: 在哪拆快递
Tasha: Where do we open the packages?
Jake: 呃那边有一些快递
Jake: Uh, there are some packages over there.
Jake: 然后就过来拆
Jake: Then we can open them here.
Katrina:  我要整一波我的
Katrina: I'm going to open mine now.
Tasha: 我还有在菜鸟驿站的
Tasha: I still have some at the Cainiao station.
Jake: 嗯哦我看一下他们
Jake: Hmm, let me check on them.
Shure:  哪里是你的
Shure: Which ones are yours?
Katrina:  都是我的都是你的
Katrina: They're all mine. They're all yours.
Katrina:  这这也是我的哎
Katrina: This one is also mine.
Katrina:  有剪刀吗
Katrina: Do you have scissors?
Alice:有有有
Alice: Yes, yes, I do.
Tasha: 这俩脚
Tasha: These two feet.
Lucia: 哈哈好奇怪啊
Lucia: Haha, it's so weird.
Lucia: 怎么会呢
Lucia: How could it be?
Katrina:  这买多少个来着
Katrina: How many did you buy?
Alice: 汉服不是在边边
Alice: Isn't the Hanfu on the side?
Lucia: 他在边也
Lucia: It's on the side too.
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 这个有没有一点苦
Lucia: Does this taste a bit bitter?
Lucia: 有没有一点点像啊有可能
Lucia: Does it taste a bit similar? Maybe.
Shure:  what's this
Shure: What's this?
Katrina:  这就是压花器
Katrina: This is a flower press.
Katrina:  就是你把那个鲜花放进去
Katrina: You put fresh flowers in it.
Katrina:  它就会变成干花
Katrina: And they turn into dried flowers.
Katrina:  买几个
Katrina: How many did you buy?
Katrina:  一个哎三三个
Katrina: One, no, three.
Tasha: 别把他漏了
Tasha: Don't forget this one.
Tasha: 4个漏出来
Tasha: Four got left out.
Lucia: 这个地方他偏平一点
Lucia: This area is flatter.
Lucia: 这是不是一个相对平坦的一个表面
Lucia: Isn't this a relatively flat surface?
Lucia: 嗯显得太小
Lucia: Hmm, it looks too small.
Lucia: 有可能会是这样
Lucia: It might be like this.
Tasha: 啊不行啊这是太平了
Tasha: Ah, no, it's too flat.
Tasha: 衣服湿了
Tasha: The clothes are wet.
Lucia: 一般相似先放在这里好了
Lucia: Usually, similar things are placed here.
Tasha: 那把它按在这里面的哪里呢
Tasha: So where do we press it in here?
Lucia: 哈哈哈好问题
Lucia: Haha, good question.
Lucia: 这个有可能吧
Lucia: Maybe.
Lucia: 是不是也不太可能呀
Lucia: Or maybe not.
Lucia: 好迷惑啊我
Lucia: I'm so confused.
Lucia: 我小时候玩那个1,000块拼图
Lucia: When I was a kid, I used to play with that 1,000-piece puzzle.
Lucia: 从来没有拼出来过
Lucia: I never finished it.
Tasha: 真的吗对我每次后面有数字
Tasha: Really? Mine always had numbers on the back.
Lucia: 啊是吗
Lucia: Oh, really?
Tasha: 是呀哎
Tasha: Yeah, totally.
Lucia: 那难道我买的是盗版的
Lucia: Did I buy a fake one then?
Lucia: 反正我就是
Lucia: Anyway, I...
Lucia: 我好不容易拼了其中的一部分
Lucia: I managed to put together a part of it.
Lucia: 然后就不会拼了
Lucia: And then I couldn't continue.
Lucia: 然后我就放弃
Lucia: So, I just gave up.
Alice: 好难呀玩困了怎么办怎么说呢
Alice: It's so hard. What to do if you get sleepy while playing?
Alice: 这个应该催眠了
Alice: This should be hypnotizing.
Shure:  喝杯咖啡吧
Shure: Have a cup of coffee.
Tasha: 嗯
Shure: 搞杯咖啡喝
Lucia: 太难了
Lucia: It's too hard.
Alice: 速度感觉他俩是不是也可以这样
Alice: At this speed, do you think they could finish it too?
Alice: 就一点点就成这样了
Alice: Just a little more and it will be done.
Shure:  这么多
Shure: So much.
Katrina:  对但是我以为每
Katrina: Yeah, but I thought everyone...
Katrina:  个人都要做一到两
Katrina: has to do one or two...
Katrina:  边边都不播放了
Katrina: parts and then it won't play anymore.
Tasha: 怎么回事
Tasha: What's going on?
Tasha: 大家挤一挤
Tasha: Everybody squeeze in.
Lucia: 哈哈电不够了
Lucia: Haha, not enough power.
Tasha: 嗯大家积极勉强
Tasha: Okay, everyone, try your best.
Tasha: 哎就这样
Tasha: Alright, like this.
Lucia: 就是这样的哈哈
Lucia: That's how it is, haha.
Lucia: 非常对
Lucia: Exactly.
Alice: 我感觉边是对了但我感觉这有点大
Alice: I feel the edge is correct, but it seems a bit large.
Alice: 嗯但是感觉这边要重新组合组合
Alice: Yeah, but I think this part needs to be reassembled.
Shure: 它又没电了是吗
Jake:我不知道它为什么
Tasha: 我觉得这边没问题
Tasha: I think this part is fine.
Tasha: 这边这边有问题
Tasha: This part, this part has issues.
Jake:断了它有点它就断
Tasha: 要把这几个重新组合一下
Tasha: We need to reassemble these pieces.
Tasha: 但还是这几个边
Tasha: But still these edges.
Lucia: 总感觉这个牛
Lucia: I always feel this cow...
Lucia: 这里他应该能放一个什么东西进来
Lucia: Here, it should be able to fit something in.
Lucia: 但是是的
Lucia: But yes.
Lucia: 难道他也是一个
Lucia: Could it also be...
Lucia: 障眼法吗
Lucia: an illusion?
Katrina:  这样就可以
Katrina: This will work.
Lucia: 这个看起来其实也像在边上一样
Lucia: This actually looks like it's on the edge too.
Lucia: 看就是如果如果这样的话是吧
Lucia: See, if it's like this, right?
Katrina:  你这个花瓶呢
Katrina: What about this vase?
Katrina:  快递在哪看到的哦
Katrina: Where did you see the package?
Alice: 花瓶不是快递
Alice: The vase isn't a package.
Alice: 就在桌子上
Alice: It's just on the table.
Alice: 有两个瓶子
Alice: There are two vases.
Shure: 我买了6个啊
Shure: I bought six of them.
Katrina:  哎哦啊啊啊这个哎
Katrina: Oh, this one, oh, ah, oh.
Jake:哪一个
Jake: Which one?
Tasha: 取得了历史性的进步啊
Tasha: Made some historic progress.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我们刚发现这是这样的
Lucia: Hahaha, we just found out it's like this.
Lucia: 然后这样又可以拼上哦
Lucia: And then, we can piece it together again.
Tasha: 历史性的进步
Tasha: Historic progress.
Lucia: 不错不错
Lucia: Not bad, not bad.
Lucia: 胜利在望哈哈
Lucia: Victory is in sight, haha.
Jake: 你买了几个花瓶
Jake: How many vases did you buy?
Katrina:  6个我当时想的是一人一个放下
Katrina: Six. I thought each person could have one.
Katrina:  嗯6个花瓶
Katrina: Yeah, six vases.
Shure: 放不下呀
Jake: 厨房看到了吗
Jake: Did you check the kitchen?
Jake: 看到了几个
Jake: How many did you see?
Shure: 不行啊
Shure: 这弧度跟这个很像
Shure: 是的
Alice: 但是这感觉
Alice: But this feels...
Lucia: 这个有可能在里面
Lucia: This one might be inside.
Lucia: 感觉它看起来好像都不太圆对吧
Lucia: It doesn't look very round, right?
Lucia: 嗯先把它放出来
Lucia: Hmm, let's take it out first.
Lucia: 熊猫哎这个也很像在边上
Lucia: Panda, this one also looks like it's on the edge.
Lucia: 有道理
Lucia: Makes sense.
Katrina:  确实发了三个快递
Katrina: I did send out three packages.
Katrina:  但是都到了
Katrina: But they all arrived.
Tasha: 你们换个边
Tasha: You guys switch sides.
Alice: 更不像哎
Alice: Looks even less like it now.
Tasha: 这个感觉屏有点那种弧度是他吗
Tasha: This screen has a bit of a curve, is it this one?
Alice: 不是不是这个也不是
Alice: No, no, it's not this one either.
Lucia: 这样的话嗯好像也放不进去
Lucia: If we do it this way, hmm, it still doesn't fit.
Lucia: 这些东西有可能吗
Lucia: Could these things actually fit?
Jake: 哎我拼几个这个吧
Jake: Hey, let me put these together.
Jake: 这个有用吗
Jake: Is this useful?
Jake: 这个这个要不
Jake: How about this one?
Jake: 把白板给放下去
Jake: Put the whiteboard down.
Shure: 放下去吧
Jake: 就是把白板给赶到这个上面就不行了
Jake: It won't work if the whiteboard is on top of this.
Shure:  要的那么写太费劲了
Lucia: 怎么会呢
Lucia: How come?
Katrina:  花都在这
Katrina: The flowers are here.
Jake: 哇你已经弄好了
Jake: Wow, you've already done it.
Lucia: 怎么会呢
Lucia: How come?
Jake: 剪刀
Shure: 剪刀
Katrina:  剪刀在外面
Katrina: The scissors are outside.
Katrina:  这加水了吗
Katrina: Did you add water to this?
Jake: 加过了
Jake: Yes, I did.
Katrina:  加过了是吧
Katrina: You did, right?
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Lucia: 哇哇
Lucia: Wow, wow.
Alice: 太难了
Alice: This is so hard.
Lucia: 拼图天才
Lucia: Puzzle genius.
Alice: 哈哈天才又找到一块
Alice: Haha, the genius found another piece.
Katrina: 好厉害
Katrina: So impressive.
Tasha: 拼图天才
Tasha: Puzzle genius.
Tasha: 出山出山
Jake: 真有意思
Jake: Really interesting.
Lucia: 让我们看看有没有可能
Lucia: Let's see if it's possible.
Lucia: 在不依靠
Lucia: Without relying on...
Lucia: 解析的情况下
Lucia: Analysis.
Jake: 这尾巴试过
Jake: Tried the tail.
Alice: 有点大
Alice: It's a bit big.
Lucia: 这个呢有可能
Lucia: What about this one, maybe?
Lucia: 不太行
Lucia: Not quite.
Lucia: 现在谁在中间呢
Lucia: Who's in the middle now?
Tasha: 嗯刚刚这个好像不太行
Tasha: Hmm, this one doesn't seem to work.
Alice: 他又跟谁分家了
Alice: Who's he teamed up with now?
Tasha: 对他他在这
Tasha: Yeah, he's here.
Tasha: 哎把小伙伴丢了
Tasha: Oh, he lost his buddy.
Lucia: 哦这个这个这个在他的那个
Lucia: Oh, this, this, this is on his...
Lucia: sorry忘记了
Lucia: Sorry, I forgot.
Lucia: 嗯对这是这样子的
Lucia: Yeah, that's how it is.
Lucia: 对对对这块就这样挺好
Lucia: Right, right, this part is good.
Tasha: 这样子挺好的
Tasha: This is pretty good.
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This...
Tasha: 这个还不确定在哪
Tasha: This is still uncertain.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm...
Tasha: 不确定的放中间吧
Tasha: Let's put the uncertain ones in the middle.
Alice: 你觉得这个像不像
Alice: Do you think this looks like it?
Tasha: 像嗯
Tasha: Yeah, it does.
Alice: 好好先找找你的位置
Alice: Alright, first find your spot.
Katrina:  所有快递都在外面了吗
Katrina: Are all the packages outside?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 今天还到了几个
Jake: More arrived today.
Jake: 但是还都会有管家过来送
Jake: But there will still be the housekeeper to deliver them.
Shure:  还有管家
Shure: There's still a housekeeper?
Tasha: 那他能把我的送来吗
Tasha: Can he bring mine too?
Jake: 什么东西啊
Jake: What is it?
Jake: 把什么东西
Jake: Bring what?
Tasha: 把我买的东西
Tasha: The things I bought.
Tasha: 那应该是很好的
Tasha: They should be good.
Jake: 可以啊今天会有吗
Jake: Sure, will they arrive today?
Jake: 我问一下他们什么时候能
Jake: I'll ask them when they can...
Jake: 能来送
Jake: ...come and deliver them.
Tasha: 好这游戏三个人玩刚刚好结果我们的是
Tasha: Okay, this game is perfect for three people. So, our team is...
Alice: 掌管120组
Alice: In charge of 120 groups.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 不太像
Lucia: Not really.
Alice: 他俩会不会一家的
Alice: Could they be from the same family?
Tasha: 他们仨是不是一个家的
Tasha: Are the three of them from the same family?
Lucia: 有可能但是总觉得哎对不起对不起
Lucia: Maybe, but it always feels... oh, sorry, sorry.
Lucia: 这里是不是应该稍微弧度再推一点
Lucia: Should we push this curve a bit more here?
Tasha: 可是感觉不是那么严丝合缝
Tasha: But it doesn't feel like a perfect fit.
Lucia: 要不然的话
Lucia: Otherwise...
Tasha: 他们俩的宽度最匹配
Tasha: Their width matches the best.
Lucia: 姑且对
Lucia: For now, yes.
Lucia: 然后放一下
Lucia: Then let's put it here.
Tasha: 或者这个呢
Tasha: Or how about this one?
Tasha: 这两个都有可能
Tasha: Both of these are possible.
Katrina:  要帮忙不
Katrina: Need some help?
Lucia: 也太难了吧
Lucia: This is too hard.
Alice: 哎你觉得这个像不像在这
Alice: Hey, do you think this looks like it belongs here?
Tasha: 这样子的这样像不像
Tasha: Does it look like this?
Lucia: 诶是这儿
Lucia: Hey, it's here.
Katrina:  我可以
Katrina: I can do it.
Alice:不过感觉应该跟哪都行啊
Alice: But it feels like it could go anywhere.
Katrina:  帮你们拧螺丝
Katrina: I'll help you guys tighten the screws.
Alice: 只不过这个头对着他的屁股
Alice: But this head is facing his butt.
Alice: 好像也挺严丝合缝的
Alice: It seems to fit quite snugly.
Tasha: 这个这个是对的
Tasha: This, this is correct.
Lucia: 在一起的
Lucia: Together.
Jake: 喜欢拧螺丝
Jake: Like tightening screws.
Jake: 就是刚刚拧的太紧了
Jake: Just now, I tightened it too much.
Lucia: 还有这个我们的配对
Lucia: And this, our pairing.
Jake: 对对要不装个机
Jake: Yeah, yeah, how about we assemble a PC?
Tasha: 咱俩配对啊
Tasha: Pair up, us two?
Shure:  要不咱装个机
Shure: How about we build a PC?
Jake: 好给你买一个台电脑
Jake: Okay, I'll buy you a computer.
Jake: 从头装哇
Jake: We'll build it from scratch.
Tasha: 不太相像
Tasha: Not really similar.
Jake: 怎么出来的
Jake: How did it come out?
Tasha: 这个是吗
Tasha: Is this it?
Alice: 有长这样的吗
Alice: Does it look like this?
Lucia: 没有吧
Lucia: I don't think so.
Tasha: 这个也有点像
Tasha: This one looks a bit similar too.
Lucia: 嗯因为好像
Lucia: Hmm, because it seems like...
Tasha: 长这样的
Tasha: It looks like this.
Tasha: 这不像应该不是
Tasha: This one doesn't seem right.
Lucia: 他们应该不是
Lucia: They probably aren't.
Tasha: 这个暂且配对吧
Tasha: Let's pair this for now.
Alice:不能加这里
Alice: Can't add it here.
Alice: 但我感觉这样应该
Alice: But I feel like this should...
Jake: 这啥意思
Jake: What does this mean?
Alice: 很勉强但不是不行
Alice: It's a bit forced but not impossible.
Shure: 这个呃
Jake: 试试比划
Jake: Try to compare it.
Jake: 比划
Jake: Compare.
Tasha: 这个跟谁都能配这个效果诶
Tasha: This can pair with anything, look at the result.
Shure:  你们两个的智商不看那什么可以吗
Shure: Can you not look at our IQs or whatever?
Tasha: 我就说我是个拼图天才
Tasha: I told you, I'm a puzzle genius.
Alice: 我这个在亮吗
Alice: Is this one shining?
Lucia: 哇你平时经常拼图吗
Lucia: Wow, do you often do puzzles?
Alice: 为什么感觉这是红色的
Alice: Why does this look red?
Jake: 在亮在亮
Jake: It's bright, it's bright,
Shure:  在亮在亮没问题看一下安装图纸
Jake: 是红色你这电量太少了
Jake: It's red because your battery is too low.
Jake: 我看一下你的这个电在哪啊
Jake: Let me check where your battery is.
Shure:  这个是我我看一下这个对
Shure: This is me, let me see this, okay.
Shure:  放下面的
Shure: Put it at the bottom.
Katrina:  这是什么
Katrina: What's this?
Katrina:  跟他对接
Katrina: Connect it to this.
Shure:  这有两个螺丝
Shure: There are two screws here.
Alice: 这在录吗
Alice: Is this recording?
Jake: 这个在录
Jake: This is recording.
Jake: 然后这个正在车
Jake: And this one is moving.
Jake: 所以没关系
Jake: So it's fine.
Jake: 然后吧对
Jake: And then, yeah.
Jake: 这就是电开关
Jake: This is the power switch.
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Jake: 这是干嘛的
Jake: What's this for?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina:  叠开关
Katrina: Toggle switch.
Katrina:  游戏
Katrina: Game.
Katrina:  高度调节
Katrina: Height adjustment.
Jake: 安装图这个样子
Jake: The installation manual looks like this.
Jake: 这样是吧
Jake: Like this, right?
Jake: 这两个是这这是这嗯
Jake: These two are, this is, uh-huh.
Jake: 下面这是什么
Jake: What's this at the bottom?
Jake: 下面还有一条
Jake: There's another line at the bottom.
Katrina:  你把它反过来是不是这个
Katrina: If you flip it over, is it this one?
Jake: oh
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  holy shit
Shure: Holy shit.
Shure:  what
Shure: What?
Shure:  耶
Shure: Yeah.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 嗯不行
Lucia: Hmm, not working.
Katrina:  要这样弄紧靠紧
Katrina: You have to do it like this, tighten it.
Shure:  这样把这边然后
Shure: Do it like this, and then...
Jake: 哪个距离不对吗
Jake: Is the distance not right?
Lucia: 诶
Lucia: Hey.
Katrina:  确实该弄长一点
Katrina: It should indeed be a bit longer.
Lucia: 嗯中间这个中间是谁感觉
Lucia: Hmm, who is this in the middle?
Jake: 这个有点别扭的感觉
Jake: This feels a bit awkward.
Jake: 这个大概是这个哎
Jake: This is probably this one, hey.
Jake: 他是有斜度吗
Jake: Does it have a slope?
Jake: 还是他是直的呀
Jake: Or is it straight?
Lucia: 感觉不是这个形状
Lucia: It doesn't seem to be this shape.
Jake: 但我觉得
Jake: But I think...
Tasha: 他俩好像是一起的
Tasha: They seem to be together.
Katrina:  他这个长度放倒紧一些
Katrina: This length makes it tight when laid down.
Jake: 他这个他这个得弄长一点吗
Jake: Does this need to be longer?
Katrina:  可以他是可以调节长度的对
Katrina: Yes, it can be adjusted for length.
Lucia: 这样的话
Lucia: If so...
Lucia: 是他是他
Lucia: Yes, it's him.
Jake: 哎不对不对不对不是这个得
Jake: Hey, no no no, it's not this one.
Alice: 可能他不在就是这个只是大概的
Alice: Maybe he's not here, this is just approximate.
Jake: 然后这个
Jake: And this one...
Lucia: 如果真的在一块儿的话
Lucia: If they are really together...
Lucia: 那就变成这样了
Lucia: Then it becomes like this.
Lucia: 但是我找不到了
Lucia: But I can't find it.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Tasha: 从中间这个如果没有的话就不是
Tasha: If the middle one isn't there, then it's not right.
Tasha: 嗯好难呀
Tasha: Hmm, this is so hard.
Alice: 确实哎
Alice: Indeed, yeah.
Jake:以后咱用尺
Jake: We should use a ruler next time.
Shure: 没事整个大概就行
Tasha: 是他们俩对还是他们俩对
Tasha: Is it these two or those two?
Shure:  不这样嗯我们先把一一边固定上就好了
Shure: How about this, we fix one side first.
Shure:  让他不乱窜
Shure: So it doesn't move around.
Katrina: 嗯嗯
Katrina: Hmm hmm.
Jake: 固定一个吧
Jake: 或者应该倒倒下来得了倒下来
Jake: Or maybe turn it upside down, turn it upside down.
Lucia: 有点难搞
Lucia: This is a bit tricky.
Lucia: 感觉拼困了累了歇一歇
Lucia: I feel tired from piecing it together, let's take a break.
Lucia: 他们在那边拼那个需要帮忙呢
Lucia: They are assembling that over there, need some help?
Tasha: 哎怎么
Tasha: Hey, how...
Lucia: 看一眼
Lucia: Take a look.
Shure:  那个拿拿
Katrina:  可以
Katrina: Oh no.
Jake: 你们拼完了
Jake: Are you guys done assembling?
Lucia: 没有
Lucia: No.
Jake: 先休息一会是吧
Jake: Let's take a break first, right?
Shure:  对拼困了
Shure: Yes, I'm exhausted.
Lucia: 决定看看有没有什么其他可以帮忙的
Lucia: Decided to see if there's anything else I can help with.
Jake: 我们房间要不要
Jake: Should we...
Jake: 可能要装饰一下
Jake: Maybe decorate the room a bit?
Jake: 要不我们踩个风
Jake: Or should we take a walk?
Lucia: 也可以
Lucia: Sure.
Lucia: 我们是只只把一楼这个客厅装饰一下
Lucia: Should we just decorate the living room on the first floor?